BUT FIRST, RIOTS AT THE COURT.
THAT’S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
ANGLE.
FOR DECADES AND DECADES,
CONSERVATIVES HAVE BEEN
DISAPPOINTED BY THE SUPREME
COURT’S TURN FROM BEING A FAIRLY
APOLITICAL INSTITUTION THAT
CALLS BALLS AND STRIKES AND
LEAVES MOST OF THE BIG POLICY
DECISIONS TO ELECTED OFFICIALS
TO IN ACTIVIST BODY PRESSING
LIBERAL SOCIAL GOALS ON THE REST
OF US.
READING MIRANDA RIGHTS UNDER THE
CONSTITUTION, THAT WAS ONE
THING.
BUT IN 1973, EVERYTHING CHANGED
WITH ROE VS. WADE.
JUST AS HARRY BLACKMUN AND SIX
OTHERS USED THE DUE PROCESS
CLAUSE OF THE 14TH AMENDMENT TO
STRIKE DOWN A STATE LAW
PROHIBITING ABORTION.
WHICH THEN TOOK THE ISSUE AWAY
FROM ALL 50 STATES.
AND NOTHING HAS BEEN THE SAME
SINCE.
MORE THAN ANY OTHER, THAT CASE
SET THE PRECEDENT FOR THE
QUARTET ACT IS KIND OF A SUPER
LEGISLATURE TO IMPOSE A NEW
SOCIAL ORDER ON THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
ONE UNELECTED LIFE TENURED
JUDGES ENDED UP TAKING POWER
AWAY FROM THE PEOPLE AND
EXERCISING IT THEMSELVES, THAT
CREATED A HUGE FISSURE IN
AMERICA.
OUR FRAMERS NEVER ENVISIONED
THAT A HANDFUL OF UNACCOUNTABLE
JURISTS WOULD HAVE SUCH OUTSIZED
INFLUENCE.
THAT’S EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED.
CONSERVATIVES HAVE BEEN
PATIENTLY WAITING AND PATIENTLY
WORKING TO REPAIR THIS DAMAGE TO
OUR CONSTITUTIONAL SYSTEM FOR AS
LONG AS I HAVE BEEN ALIVE, THEY
HAVE BEEN TRYING.
THEY EMERGED, RAISE MONEY, WE
HAVE ALL VOTED FOR CANDIDATES
WHO PROMISED TO RESTORE THE
SEPARATION OF POWERS TO ITS
RIGHTFUL PLACE.
BUT OFTEN WE HAVE COME UP SHORT.
TOO OFTEN, JUSTICE IS BY
REPUBLICANS AND UP EVOLVING TO
THE LEFT.
FROM WILLIAM BRENNAN AND
EISENHOWER KNOW MANY TO
WARREN BURGER, ONE OF NIXON’S
PICKS, TO DAVID SOUTER, OF BUSH
41 FAME, AND JOHN ROBERTS,
BUSH 43 APPOINTEE.
IN SEMINAL CASES THEY HAVE
ABANDONED THE PRINCIPLE OF
JUDICIAL RESTRAINT ENJOYING THE
ACTIVIST LIBERALS.
ONE OF MY EARLIEST MEMORIES AS A
YOUNG REAGAN ADMINISTRATION
STAFFER WAS WATCHING THE ROBERT
BORK HEARING BACK IN 1987.
WHAT THEY DID TO HIM WAS VICIOUS
POLITICAL BLOOD SPORT.
REPUBLICANS WEREN’T READY THEN
TO FIGHT BACK.
A FEW YEARS LATER, HE WARNED
ABOUT JUDGES BECOMING SOCIAL
JUSTICE WARRIORS.
>> THERE’S TWO KINDS OF
JUSTICES.
ONE, THE KIND THAT JUDGES SHOULD
BE CONCERNED WITH HIS JUSTICE
UNDER LAW WHICH MEANS APPLYING
THE LAW FULLY AND FAIRLY.
THERE’S A HIGHER JUSTICE WHICH
IS JUSTICE ACCORDING TO
MORALITY.
THAT’S REALLY NOT FOR JUDGES.
AS FOR LEGISLATORS AND FOR
OURSELVES TO ENACT OUR
PRINCIPLES OF MORALITY INTO LAW
WHICH THE JUDGES SHOULD RESPECT
AND APPLIED.
>> Laura: DEMOCRATS SAVAGED
HIM BECAUSE THEY DIDN’T LIKE THE
FACT THAT HE WAS A STRICT
CONSTRUCTIONIST.
THEY WERE MOTIVATED SOLELY BY
THEIR DESIRE TO PROTECT THEIR
HOLY GRAIL OF ABORTION.
THEY REJECTED HIS NOMINATION.
ANTHONY KENNEDY WENT TO THE
COURT INSTEAD.
JUSTICE KENNEDY WAS A VERY NICE
MAN BUT HE’D SPENT DECADES
DISCIPLINING THE VOTERS WHO PUT
REAGAN IN OFFICE.
CONSERVATIVES SOLDIERED ON
WITHIN THE CONSTITUTIONAL
FRAMEWORK AND WE WERE TOLD WE
HAD TO GET CONTROL OF OUR OWN
PARTY AND THEN WIN AT THE BALLOT
BOX TO AFFECT CHANGE OF THE
COURT.
THAT’S WHAT WE DID.
WE DID IT WITH TRUMP’S VICTORY
IN 2016.
AND NOW THAT WE HAVE A CHANCE TO
PUT A FIFTH JUDICIAL
CONSERVATIVE ON THE COURT, I
KNOW LONGER COUNT ROBERTS AS
ONE, DEMOCRATS ARE THREATENING
TO BLOW UP THE ENTIRE SYSTEM.
HENCE THE TITLE OF "THE ANKLE."
RIOT AT THE COURT.
THEY CLAIM IF THEY WIN THE
SENATE THEY WILL PACK THE CAR BY
ADDING NEW JUSTICES, EXPANDING
IT, SOMETHING THAT HASN’T BEEN
THREATENED AND TRIED SINCE 1937
WHAT FDR TRIED AND FAILED TO
MOLD COURT IN HIS FAVOR.
>> LET THIS MOMENT RADICALIZING.
IF MITCH McCONNELL IS NOT
GOING TO HONOR RBG’S FINAL WISH,
WE WILL.
STICKER DEMOCRATS ARE SAYING
THAT WE WILL PACK THE COURTS.
WHAT WITH THE IMPACT BE?
>> YOU’VE ESSENTIALLY CHEATED
AND STOLE AN TWO SEATS, AND I
THINK THEY’D BE WELL WITHIN
THEIR RIGHTS TO DO SO.
>> JUSTICES NEED TO BE PLACED ON
ADDITIONALLY.
>> Laura: UNBELIEVABLE,
OUTRAGEOUS.
RUTH BADER GINSBURG PASSES AWAY
THE AGE OF 87.
THE CONSTITUTION GIVES THE SOLE
RIGHT TO NOMINATE HER
REPLACEMENT TO THE SITTING
PRESIDENT WHO IS
DONALD J. TRUMP, PERIOD.
IF HIS PARTY HAS CONTROL OF THE
SENATE, THEY HAVE THE POWER TO
MOVE A NOMINEE TO A FULL SENATE
VOTE.
THEY DIDN’T GET THESE POWERS BY
ACCIDENT.
IT WASN’T A MISTAKE.
THEY GOT THEM FROM THE VOTERS
WHO GAVE PRESIDENT TRUMP OVER
300 ELECTORAL VOTES AND WHO GAVE
REPUBLICANS 53 53 SENATORS IN TH
SENATE.
THAT’S HOW OUR SYSTEM WORKS.
NOW THE LEFT WOULD HAVE US
IGNORE THE ENTIRE CONSTITUTIONAL
SYSTEM BECAUSE OF SOMETHING THE
DECEASED JUSTICE SUPPOSEDLY SAID
IN HER FINAL DAYS?
>> HER LAST WISH, FOR THE VOTERS
TO DECIDE WHO WILL BE THE NEXT
PRESIDENT BEFORE PUSHING AHEAD
TO FILL HER SEAT.
>> SHE SAID MY MOST FERVENT WISH
IS THAT I WILL NOT BE REPLACED
UNTIL A NEW PRESIDENT IS
INSTALLED.
WE BELIEVE THAT.
>> DEFYING THAT DYING WISHES OF
MORMON SPENT HER LIFE DEVOTED TO
REALIZING THE FULL PROMISE OF
THE CONSTITUTION.
>> Laura: THE FULL PROMISE OF
THE CONSTITUTION IS IN THE
CONSTITUTION.
IMAGINE IF WE TOOK THAT ATTITUDE
AT ANY OF THE, I DON’T KNOW, 500
OCCASIONS WHEN WE LOST A BIG
CASE OF THE COURT OR WHEN BORK’S
NOMINATION WENT SOUTH OR MAYBE
AFTER THEY HORRIBLY MISTREATED
BRETT KAVANAUGH.
IMAGINE IF WE HAD REACTED LIKE
THEY DID.
THE DEMOCRATS WOULD HAVE BEEN
SCREAMING BLOODY HELL.
OH AND BY THE WAY SINCE THEY
DON’T LIKE THE FACT THAT THE
G.O.P. HAS A MAJORITY, THEY
ARE ALSO THREATENING TO PACK THE
SENATE.
THAT’S SOMETHING THAT’S NEVER
BEEN ATTEMPTED.
>> THEY CAN ABOLISH THE
FILIBUSTER.
THEY CAN GRANT STATEHOOD.
TO D.C. AND PUERTO RICO.
>> COURT REFORM, STATEHOOD FOR
D.C., PUERTO RICO.
>> NONE OF THAT HAPPENS IF THE
DEMOCRATS DO NOT TAKE BACK THE
SENATE.
>> WHAT WE WILL DO IS VERY
SIMPLE.
WE WILL ADD D.C. AND PUERTO RICO
PUERTO RICO AS STATES.
THAT’S FOUR NEW SENATORS.
SPEAK >> Laura: WHY STOP AT
FOUR?
KEEP IT GOING.
OH, BY THE WAY, GETS WORSE.
IF THOSE THREATS FAIL THEIR
SURROGATES WILL TRY
OLD-FASHIONED PHYSICAL THREATS
AS WELL.
>> WE NEED TO BE OUT IN THE
STREETS.
WE NEED PROTEST EVERYTHING ALL
DAY.
>> Laura: REMEMBER WHAT I SAID
BACK IN JANUARY OF 2019 ABOUT
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ?
I THINK IT’S A MISTAKE FOR
CONSERVATIVES NOT TO TAKE HER
SERIOUSLY, TO BRUSH HER OFF THIS
KIND OF A FLASH IN THE PAN OR AN
UPSTART.
SHE IS AS CLOSE TO A THOUGHT
LEADER AT THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
HAS TODAY.
THIS ENTIRE UNHINGED RESPONSE TO
THE RBG REPLACEMENT IS BEING
DRIVEN BY THE FAR LEFT OF THE
PARTY, AOC PLUS THREE PLUS
WHATEVER ELSE SHE’S GOING TO
DRAG ALONG WITH HER.
BIDEN WAS BASICALLY HIDING MOST
OF THE WEEKEND.
THE MAN DOESN’T EVEN KNOW WHAT
TO DO.
SURELY THE LEADER OF THE SENATE
DEMOCRATS ISN’T APPEARING WITH A
FRESHMAN CONGRESSWOMAN ON A
MATTER THAT THE HOUSE HAS ZERO
AUTHORITY OVER.
WOULDN’T DO THAT, RIGHT?
CHUCK SCHUMER.
OH, YES, HE WOULD.
>> WOULD YOU BE IN SUPPORT OF
POTENTIALLY REDOING HEARINGS
AGAINST THE ATTORNEY GENERAL OR
THE PRESIDENT.
>> WE MUST CONSIDER ALL THE
TOOLS AVAILABLE TO OUR DISPOSAL.
ALL THESE OPTIONS SHOULD BE
ENTERTAINED AND ON THE TABLE.
>> Laura: SCHUMER IS
EMBARRASSING HIMSELF AND SO WAS
EVERYONE ELSE IN THE PARTY.
THEY ARE SO OBSESSED WITH
BEATING TRUMP AND HIS VOTERS
THAT THEY ARE WILLING TO DESTROY
OUR ENTIRE SYSTEM OF CHECKS AND
BALANCES TO DO SO.
ALLOWING THE RADICAL LEFT TO
CALL ALL THE SHOTS.
WE PREDICTED HERE ON "THE
ANGLE."
BIDEN CAN’T GET CONTROL OF THESE
PEOPLE.
HE IS AN EMPTY VESSEL TO BE
FILLED WITH RADICAL POLICIES BY
RADICAL POLITICIANS WHO HATE OUR
HISTORY, HATE MOST OF OUR
TRADITIONS, AND HATE MOST OF OUR
PEOPLE.
HE IS TOO WEAK TO CONTROL THE
YOUNG BOLSHEVIKS.
HE DOESN’T HAVE A SHORT MYSTERY
DIRECT THEIR EFFORTS.
AND NOW HIS ENTIRE PARTY IS
GOING OFF THE RAILS.
THE REAL CHOICE IN THIS ELECTION
HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH BIDEN.
IT’S A CHOICE BETWEEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND THE HARD
LEFT.
THIS CONFIRMATION BATTLE WILL
SHOW US JUST HOW CRAZY THE OTHER
SIDE IS.
REPUBLICANS ARE DOING WHAT THEY
PROMISED TO DO FOR DECADES, TO
PUT ORIGINALISTS AND TEXTUALIST
ON THE COURT.
WE HAVE NEVER PROPOSED PACKING
THE COURT ARE TRYING TO ADD NEW
STATES.
THOSE THREATS ARE ONLY COMING
FROM ONE SIDE.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS NO
LONGER THE PARTY OF CLINTON OR
EVEN OBAMA FOR THAT MATTER.
IT IS THE ABORTION PARTY.
IT IS AOC’S PARTY.
FOR THAT, THEY ARE WILLING TO
DESTROY EVERYTHING WE AMERICANS
BUILT TOGETHER OVER 244 YEARS.
ONE ISSUE.